Các bạn có qua 1 xong tháng 2 năm hành hủ chăm 2 mấy sấu,
tông tin từ công an tỉnh lần đồng, đơn vị đã xa quy định hợi tổ của an,
khởi tổ bị cân đời với nguyễn thiện học lần,
sinh năm 1987, chú phần năm 2018, tỉnh khánh hoa,
về tổ trên báo văn hỏa phần đổi chuyện.
Chứ đó, qua công tác nghi vụ phòng an đến mạng và phòng trống tội phạm sự dụng công nghệ cao,
công an tỉnh lần đồng, và hiện là đến một cái sạn trên địa bản đời là
qua và phát triệu tiếp các video có lựu dụng khư giâm lên mạng sở hội nhằm thú nguyễn sè,
kiếm tin, làm việc với cỡ quan công an,
bý kân đã thử nhận tổng bộ hành bý vị phạm,
công quan công an quyền cao, việc sản sất tạm chứ,
phát tán, chia sẻ văn hỏa phần đổi chuyện giới mọi hình thức đều là hành bý vị phạm pháp lột,
có thể bị sự phát thành chính hoặc chuyện cứu chết nghiệm hình sự.
Điều sè, chia sẻ, bình luật phát lại các video,
hình hình hình hình thư giâm trên mạng của là hình bý tế tay cho vì phạm pháp lột.
Phòng trong hình bý trình má văn hoa phẩm đổi chuyện là chết nghiệm của tòan sả hội.
Bớm nha dân cình cân nân cao ý thức, chủ động phát hiện,
tổ ra các hình bý vị phạm, trong tay sẽ dựng mua trường mạng an toàn,
bân mình, có phần bảo vệ trẻ em và giữ dính các sả sị đạo đức tôi đẹp của sả hội.